die sprachpolizei ist jetzt sozusagen
auch ins museum vorgedrungen an
einheitlichen platz wo man eigentlich
hin geht um zu lernen und dinge
kennenzulernen um kontexte zu begreifen
um dinge erklärt zu bekommen der
sachverhalt wie folgt in den staatlichen
kunstsammlungen in dresden sind 143
kunstwerke umbenannt worden weil die
ursprüngliche titel
rassistisch oder diffamierend sein soll
und das ist ein
brutaler imperialistischer akt der
jetztzeit gegen die vergangenheit wir
maßen uns jetzt also an über alles zu
richten ohne jeglichen respekt vor der
geschichte ohne jeglichen respekt von
den künstlern ohne jeglichen respekt vor
dem geschichtlichen zusammenhang und
auch noch in der arroganten weise dass
ich diejenigen die es geht gar nicht
mehr werden können wir also ihre
sehweise des ganzen gar nicht mehr hören
können für mich ist das wie gesagt ich
will mal zwei beispiele geben oder drei
gab es ein bike das ist und zwerg und
knabe und das heißt jetzt hund
kleinwüchsiger mann und junge ein
anderes werk hieß landschaft mit
mohammedaner pilgern die heißt jetzt
landschaft mit beeten den muslimen oder
aber auch die [ __ ] madonna hat das
wort die zöllner madonna heißt jetzt mal
donna mit stehendem kind die baum würde
eines eingeborenen ist nur noch die
bauhütte also da versteht er sogar ein
wenig gebildete dass das auch eine
verfälschung der sachverhalte ist für
mich ist ganz klar wer im museum
zensiert der macht sich schuldig und
jetzt haben wir schon so oft über
taliban haben geredet eigentlich sind
nur die taliban schlimmer denn die
vernichten kunst gleich ganz die ihnen
nicht ins weltbild passt
also ich habe klaus ich teile deine
meinung eins zu eins das gibt es doch
nicht was treibt ich also ich will eins
dazu sagen wenn man sich damit näher
befasst stellt man den guten willen der
täter fest also sind keine bösen
menschen die irgendetwas böses machen
wollen sondern sie wollen eigentlich die
welt besser machen ja das wollten aber
alle die kunst jemals angegriffen
verändert und vernichtet haben unsere
gesellschaft hat so viele probleme das
ist eines der hinter reinigen aber
so geht das weiter schneewittchen und
die 7 kleinwüchsigen oder was auch immer
es wird irgendwann absurd und es ist
auch
unanständig jedem der das wort zwerg in
irgendeiner form ob das eine mythische
figur ist oder was auch immer
als als als rassistisch oder missachtend
denke gerade zwei glase komischerweise
ich weiß aber nicht warum thomas mit mir
kannst du nichts also rübezahl geht ja
gerade noch also moritz werke wäre auch
abwegig bei dem aber das ist das ist
einfach in der tat wirklich jetzt eine
diskussion die wir führen wo wir andere
diskussionen führen sollten es brennt
und so viel auf den nägeln aber hier hat
irgend ein gutmensch geglaubt er muss
irgendwo eingreifen aber was ich nicht
verstehe es ein beispiel was er da auch
com porträt eines dunkelhäutigen sklaven
heißt jetzt porträt eines klar wenn das
heißt das wort dunkelhäutige schlimmer
als das wort sklave was ist ein wenig
schlimmer ich finde ich wünschte ich
also ich finde daran noch etwas anderes
völlig verrückt es könnte ja sein dass
die dunkle hautfarbe dazu beigetragen
hat dass er in seiner zeit ein sklave
war also das heißt es wird sogar der
sinnzusammenhang einfach weggelassen
ausgelöst kann man ja sagen und was mich
besonders was mich wirklich also
wirklich aufregt ist dass das in dem
museum stattfindet ich tue mir
persönlich auch schon schwer dass pippi
langstrumpf jetzt nicht mehr mit demenz
könig zu tun hat sondern mit dem wie
heißt der jetzt irgendwie
der südsee könig heißt auch das finde
ich schon ohne kleines stendal mit einer
erklärung hintendran schwierig kann aber
noch sagen es ein kinderbuch und warum
soll man kinder mit einem wort das
tatsächlich jetzt nicht mehr die zeit
passt eigentlich konfrontieren aber im
museum finde ich es wirklich für dich
ich würde immer sagen erklären erklären
erklären statt zensieren zensieren
zensieren üblich auch bei den denkmälern
also ich würde gern natürlich sagen ich
meine ich verstehe das ganze nicht wir
haben wie sie sagen probleme genug und
wir müssen jetzt nicht probleme machen
wo gar keine sind und ich sag mal wenn
man zu mir sagt wie hat das mit dem 22
ja genau also rund 2 und kabel heißt so
und jetzt kleiner mann ist für mich also
eher noch beleidigend also wenn ich sage
da ist ein zwerg und da plötzlich ein
kleinwüchsiger das ja noch etwas
ausgedehnt also der muss schon sehr viel
zeit gehabt haben und sehr viel gedanken
gehabt haben die irre geführt haben der
so was überhaupt und wie sie junge ist
übrigens auch jetzt irgendwie besser als
knabe aber ich muss sagen es war nicht
einfach für die geschichte verändern das
finde ich eigentlich das schlimme daran
hat im museum führt er das gemacht hat
würde die ja sagen will ich die
geschichte sondern das bewusstsein
verändern aber unser bewusstsein herr
grupp sie werden mir recht geben also
wir waren früher wenn sie in der nähe
aufgewachsen sind da gab es in jeder
kirche in einer dunklen ecke das
missionsziel da sei es irgend so eine
figur wenn du zehn pfennig reingesteckt
das dann legte den kopf ich finde viel
schlimmer was ich heute sehe dass wir
uns angemaßt haben in afrika zwangs zu
missionieren und zu sagen also wir
bringen euch das jesulein dass dort
keiner brauchte aber sie haben natürlich
auch schon und weiß der teufel
entwickelt also da kommen wir auf ein
ganz anderes gebiet aber alles in allem
hat niemand aus der tatsache dass wir
geld ins missions- nägeli gesteckt haben
in irgendeiner form einen rassismus
entwickelt oder irgendwelche
bösartigkeiten oder abartigkeiten gegen
gegen menschen jeglicher farbe und
jeglichen wuchses das ist uns fremd und
ich erinnere mich mein vater der mich
ans missions- nägeli geführt hat hatte
einen mitarbeiter der einen der einen
einen buckel noch sagen nein nein aber
das hin was hatte an einem kombi nennt
man das
also ein
vorprogramm stimmte
mit einem kollegen an immer gesagt www
ich höre dich ein einziges mal ein
anzügliche bemerkung über diesen mann zu
machen josef mock ist er lebt nicht mehr
du machst du irgendwann wie du macht
sich darüber lustig wie du lachst also
die erziehung das ist ja einfach dass
man sagt wir
akzeptieren diese
dinge die anders sind als wir sie
gewohnt sind aber die nicht in unser
weltbild passen als in irgendeiner form
bereicherung und nicht etwas über man
sich lustig machen das ist glaube ich
die pädagogische absicht und das wirst
du damit nicht erreichen weil du damit
natürlich so viele leute die in einer
art von weltbild groß geworden sind auch
vor den kopf stößt und dich in deiner
guten absicht eigentlich ins lächerliche
setzt also solche themen aufzugreifen
und überhaupt darüber nachzudenken
das ist ja das schlimme dass man dann am
schluss solche diskussion und führt die
dann extrem werden wo solche themen wo
man dabei gedacht da blitzt nicht
hochstilisiert werden hat wo man vorher
gar nichts dabei gedacht hat und das
finde ich viel schlimmer ich glaube das
was sie gesagt haben wir haben genug
probleme und die sollten würde ja nicht
die nicht lösen und dafür neue probleme
machen also welche fächer werde ich
morgen als rassist dargestellt wird weil
der strom mit seinem artikel hier
angekommen ist ich wollte natürlich aber
man muss darüber reden und wir haben
alle nicht mehr den mut über solche
themen so zu reden wie man über sie
reden diese runde wichtig und wie gehen
wir auch was sagen ich sehe ich ja als
ich muss schon sagen dass ich gewisse
wort änderung schon verstehen kann weil
sich natürlich auch viele angegriffen
fühlen da teilweise auch zu recht aber
ich finde die geschichte zu verändern in
welchem ort änderungen findest du
positiv zum beispiel bei dunkelhäutigen
um hier da gibt es einige aber
auf jeden fall
[Musik]
würde gerne pflichten ist ich finde
jetzt nicht schlecht ab und zu mal
darüber nachzudenken was sage ich nicht
nein quatsch wir aber in unserer iso und
mehr vokabel ein apropos dunkel also ist
den schwarzfahren schwarzgeld
schwarzwald
okay jetzt wollte ich gerade also ich
wollte gerade seinem leben den moment
aus hohlen baum also in den schwarzwald
negative kontexte sind mit schwarzem
kennzeichnet da kann man ja mal darüber
nachdenken warum das so ist ich kenne
jetzt nicht auf die idee zu sagen na ja
und deshalb sind auch schwarze
ungläubige menschen negativ genau das
aber war es ist etwas was uns angst
macht der schwarze mann hat aber nichts
mit einem dunkelhäutigen menschen für
mich ruhig von der gemeinde nicht wahr
dass viele schwarze und ich meine
beschwert sich auch keiner also die
schweiz aus gut aus im moment ich war
doch mein also der schwanz ist es noch
überall geben
so ist
die frage sein er aber enklave es wäre
die richtige farbe für die uni weiß wer
die richtige farbe wenn man diese partei
quasi nicht mehr die schwarzen ja
also angriff haben sind schon besetzt
vielleicht orange
das wieder farben unseres himmel ist
blau
fdp vielleicht das preiswachstum
kandidaten das habe ich nicht wirklich
gesagt okay das war das stimmt jetzt
habe ich ihn wirklich dabei ist ja
eigentlich auch nur kleinwüchsig
[Musik]